using Prezi I don't know if any of you
are familiar with it probably you are
I'm fairly new to it I downloaded it
last night a very brief introduction to
me my name is Jackie blue and the
headteacher chest a little high school
I'm fairly new to the position I started
this at the beginning of last year my
teaching career began before I started
teaching when I was doing my crack at
Chesterfield high school actually during
that time I volunteered some time with
the learning and support team and as a
result of that volunteering I've got a
paid teacher's aide job at the school
and then at the end of that period as I
was graduating the deputy principal at
the time recommended me to somebody who
was looking for teacher to do it at year
block an equal burn so I did my first
year teaching in England my school and
then at the end of that block I got
offered a six-month block at Ashcroft
High School then a permanent position
came up there and I applied for it and
got the position so I stayed at Ashcroft
for a total of six years so I saw one
cycle to students through from year 7 to
12 which was really awesome I really
liked that I practiced everything
founded everything at Engel burn for a
year and then I got out of there to use
a dash across my last year at Ashcroft
I was able to fulfill the role of
relieving head teacher per year my teeth
my actual head teacher said to me could
you come in for a turn at first and I
think she knew me enough to know that if
she'd have asked me to do the whole year
initially I probably would have said no
I wasn't sure if I wanted to be a head
teacher so I took on the turn at the end
of the time she said can you do time - I
said yes and then at the end of time -
she said I'm not coming back
the recipe and it was actually the best
thing that could have happened to me
when she said that she was coming back I
was hungry and ready to try a new
challenge and so I played for the job
that Chesterfield high school one of the
most important questions I think that we
need to answer is what do we teach and I
heard Judy say this when I came and met
with one of her classes a couple of
years ago I think what do we teach with
these students and it's a bit of a trick
question isn't it because it's not who
do we teach it's why do we teach but I
think if the answer to that for us at
the core is students then we're a good
starting place and why are you a teacher
I mean I think I have the absolute best
job in the whole wide well so if your
answer is something along the lines of
why your teachers because you want to
change the world
then I think that that's a good answer
to have and I think they're the two most
important questions to ask and answer
for yourself as a maths teacher and so I
really want to challenge you and provoke
that thought and you know my goodness my
thoughts have been provokes so much by
your presentation this morning I'm
exploding with questions and what about
this and what about that so what do you
teach we teach students first and
foremost and I think if if that guides
everything else that we do that then
we're in good stead to be awesome
mathematics educators so obviously the
first point to that is to know your
students and how they learn and that's
the number one element of the Australian
professional standards and I think
that's for a very very good reason
because it's the grass roots of what we
do
so I think that the the most important
thing is that we as we're giving to
schools need to be able to create and
differentiate programs we've just heard
all about that but looking at what is
going to meet the learning needs of your
students because we all have this one
syllabus to follow and we have to work
out how it's going to be the needs of
the students that walk into our
classroom and I was really encouraged by
the the plethora of ideas you gave and
how you can differentiate the learning
but again overwhelmed by how are we to
do that in my experience I've taught a
lot of different levels of maths and I
had a year a class that was obviously
staged for class but a lot of students
working at stage two entry level and in
my experience I really strongly believe
that you can teach those stage four
outcomes at a level that will meet the
needs of those students who are working
under stage two or three level I really
really believe that and you can find
really creative ways of doing it but the
most important thing is to make sure
that the curriculum is accessible by a
highly supportive environment and we can
do that by modeling and scaffolding and
creating those challenging situations
but you then support the kids to to
access so my advice to all teachers
beginning end long-term career is to be
getting out of the classroom one of the
best things that you can do as a teacher
is to get involved in whatever it is
that your school is doing and do it
because you're passionate about whatever
it is you're going to be involved in not
because it's going to look good on your
CV that stuff will come anyway if you
are getting involved in big ways and
stay involved in a grassroots level I'm
a head teacher of maths but I also run a
boxing initiative at my school we've
just started
this time a girls who are risk working
there some girls who are not at risk I
think you know what I mean when I say at
risk I've not been on engaged in school
so it was a way to get them engaged and
it is seeing improvements in their
behavior in the classroom and I think
that's really important
let's say no which is the opposite of
get involved I guess I mean say yes to
the things that you are going to give in
there and smash and change the world
with okay so whatever it is that you do
do it well and I'm gonna have to sit
down and maybe we can talk about this